en el vídeo anterior definimos nuestra
variable aleatoria x mayúscula como el
número de caras después de 5
lanzamientos esta moneda es una moneda
sin cargar y después calculamos las
diferentes probabilidades que puede
tomar esta variable aleatoria con
diferentes valores vamos a reescribir
los todos aquí la probabilidad de que
tengamos cero caras que es lo mismo que
obtener cinco cruces encontramos que era
de uno entre treinta y dos
y la probabilidad de obtener una cara
encontramos que era 5 entre 32
la probabilidad de obtener dos caras que
nuestra variable aleatoria hacia
igualados era 10 / 32
o 50 16
la probabilidad de obtener tres caras
fue igual a lo mismo 10 entre 32 que es
igual a 5 entre 16 lo cual tiene sentido
ya que la probabilidad de obtener tres
caras es la misma que la probabilidad de
obtener dos cruces y la probabilidad de
obtener dos cruces es la misma que la
probabilidad de obtener tres caras
después encontramos que la probabilidad
de obtener cuatro caras era igual a
cinco entre treinta y dos lo cual
también tiene sentido ya que la
probabilidad de obtener cuatro caras es
la misma que la probabilidad de obtener
una cruz y viceversa
finalmente la probabilidad de obtener
cinco caras que todas sean caras es la
misma que la probabilidad de no tener
ninguna cruz uno entre treinta y dos la
probabilidad de no tener ninguna cruz es
la misma que la probabilidad de tener
cinco caras vamos a dibujar esto nuestra
distribución de probabilidad dibujamos
nuestro eje x y nuestro eje y cuáles son
los diferentes valores que nos interesan
para nuestra variable aleatoria
y noten que todos estos son valores
discretos son números particulares
finitos los cuales son valores que puede
tomar nuestra variable aleatoria esa es
una función de la definición de nuestra
variable aleatoria esa variable
aleatoria el número de caras que podemos
obtener después de 5 lanzamientos no
puede tener un número infinito de
valores no estos valores van de 0 a 5
nomás lo importante aquí a darse cuenta
es que hay un número finito de valores
que puede tomar nuestra variable
aleatoria y es por eso que tenemos una
distribución de probabilidad discreta
así que tenemos que los valores de
nuestra variable aleatoria son de 0 a 5
0 1 2 3 4 5 estos son los valores que
puede tomar nuestra variable aleatoria x
el número de caras en cinco lanzamientos
y voy a dibujar primero los puntos más
altos que son 10 entre 32 y estos
ocurren cuando x es igual a 2 y cuando x
es igual a 3 así que en estos dos puntos
2 y 3
voy a dibujar una gráfica de barras
donde pongo el valor que es el mayor de
hecho por eso empiezo a dibujar estas
porque son las que tienen el mayor valor
10 entre 32 y ahora voy a dibujar las
barras que corresponden a el siguiente
valor de la probabilidad cuando x es
igual a 1 tenemos 5 entre 32 y es la
misma probabilidad para x igual a 450 32
es la mitad de 10 entre 32 así que estas
dos tienen la misma altura muy bien
ahora la probabilidad de obtener ya sea
0 o 5
ambas son iguales y este es uno entre 32
y esto va a ser una quinta parte más o
menos de esta altura así que va a lucir
más o menos así
y si está olvidando poner que en este
eje está en los valores de mi variable
aleatoria x vamos a poner aquí las
etiquetas de las alturas aquí tengo 10 /
y aquí sigue 50 y 32
y aquí un 1 entre 32
lo que acabo de dibujar es la
distribución de probabilidad binomial o
una instancia en particular de la
distribución de probabilidad binomial y
de hecho conforme ustedes se van
acercando a un número infinito de
valores aquí en esta gráfica verán que
esta va a aproximarse en forma a la
famosa curva de campana y se llama así
porque empieza a tomar cierta forma como
de campana más o menos así y quizás más
adelante veamos un ejemplo usando excel
y en lugar de decir bueno el número de
caras que salen después de cinco
lanzamientos de moneda podríamos hablar
de la probabilidad de obtener caras
después de un millón de lanzamientos de
moneda verán que estas barras comienzan
a dibujarse muy juntas entre sí y
comenzarán a aproximarse a esta forma
que parece una curva de campana
esta es una distribución muy importante
porque primero describe muchos procesos
aleatorios pero es importante en las
estadísticas en general porque muchas
veces en las estadísticas nosotros no
conocemos los mecanismos que
cuentan ocultos que generan nuestros
resultados y nosotros solamente
suponemos que es un montón de cosas
aleatorias y solo se van agregando
eventos aleatorios como lo es el contar
el número de caras que salen después de
cierto número de lanzamientos de monedas
y terminamos suponiendo que muchas cosas
al menos en el mundo discreto tienen una
distribución binomial y dentro de
algunos vídeos veremos el caso continua
que es la distribución normal y aquí es
importante que nos demos cuenta de esto
porque muchas personas hacen
suposiciones sobre ciertas cosas la
mayor de ellas y probablemente la que
tiene repercusiones más negativas sobre
todo en un ambiente financiero es
suponer que algún proceso tiene una
distribución binomial o normal cuando en
realidad no es así ya que si suponemos
que algo tiene una distribución así
comenzaremos a decir bueno la
probabilidad de estos extremos pues es
muy baja pero qué tal si la distribución
en realidad fuera de esta otra manera y
veremos más ejemplos de esto no quiero
avanzar demasiado rápido
la idea general es importante de
entender el suponer que algo tiene una
distribución binomial o normal y bueno
dicho esto ya les dio una idea de por
qué esto es importante y para revisar un
poquito más de lo que ya hemos estudiado
pensemos en por qué se llama esto
distribución de probabilidad binomial si
ustedes reflexionan en esto cuando
lanzan cinco monedas o cuando lanzan
cinco veces una moneda cada arreglo no
se puede poner aquí un arreglo aleatorio
de caras y cruces cada circunstancia de
las caras o las cruces cada una de éstas
tiene una probabilidad exactamente de 1
entre 32 ya que hay 32 maneras en las
que yo puedo dibujar una combinación de
caras y cruces en cinco posiciones
diferentes así que cada una de éstas
tiene una probabilidad de 1 entre 2 lo
que hicimos esencialmente en el vídeo
anterior cuando dijimos cuál es la
probabilidad de obtener exactamente 2
caras en esencia lo que dijimos es bueno
cuántas
estas circunstancias o cuántas de estas
no sé podríamos llamarlas permutaciones
cuántas de esas permutaciones tienen
exactamente dos caras las contamos y
encontramos que diez de ellas tienen
exactamente dos caras por eso es que la
probabilidad es de 10 en 72 la forma en
que encontramos esto es por ejemplo si
decimos bueno dos caras uno de los cinco
lanzamientos puede tener una cara y
después uno de los cuatro lanzamientos
siguientes puede tener otra cara y no
nos interesa el orden en el que aparecen
así que no nos interesa si en el primer
lanzamiento obtuvimos la primera cara y
en el segundo obtuvimos la segunda cara
o al revés por eso es que lo dividimos
entre dos y decimos que esto es lo mismo
que cinco factorial esta parte es lo
mismo que cinco factorial entre tres
factorial y esto es exactamente a tener
dos factorial y eso debajo es
exactamente lo mismo que tener dos
factorial ya que los factoriales dos por
uno así que en general vamos a
escribirlo la probabilidad de
x sea igual a n y eso es para la equis
que yo definí la variable aleatoria que
es el número de caras que obtengo en
cinco lanzamientos de moneda es igual a
5 factorial dividido entre n factorial
en este caso en es 2 ya que estamos
viendo la probabilidad de obtener dos
caras multiplicado por 5 menos 2
factorial y los invito a que revisen
esto ya que es importante obtener una
intuición de esto por eso es que los
invito a que revisen los vídeos que hice
en la lista de probabilidad sobre todo
en coeficientes binomial es y en esos
problemas de probabilidad del tipo de
lanzamiento de monedas ya que en ellos
entre con más detalle sobre la intuición
de esto pero si ustedes ya vieron esos
vídeos y ya tienen cierta experiencia
con esto podrán reconocer que este es el
coeficiente binomial incluso tengo un
vídeo de porque así se llama coeficiente
binomial ya que estos coeficientes
aparecen cuando se multiplican binomios
los binomios son este tipo de cosas que
tienen x + y comienzo a multiplicarlos
por ellos mismos con diferentes
exponenciales los coeficientes de éstos
iguales a estos e hice un vídeo dedicado
a la explicación de por qué eso sucede
porque esto funciona así y también por
qué se llama esto distribución binomial
otra forma de escribir esto de manera
más breve es de 5 elijo n y se dice de
esta manera porque decimos que tenemos 5
lanzamientos y estamos eligiendo dos de
esos lanzamientos para que sean caras o
en este caso tenemos 5 lanzamientos y
elegimos n de esos lanzamientos para
hacer caras esto nos va a decir cuántas
de las diferentes permutaciones
satisfacen nuestra condición y decimos
bueno cuál es la probabilidad de cada
una de estas pues lo multiplicaremos por
1 entre 32 es por eso que esto se llama
la distribución binomial cada uno de los
valores o las probabilidades para cada
uno de los valores de nuestra variable
aleatoria los podemos encontrar usando
los coeficientes binomial es me estoy
dando cuenta que me he quedado de nuevo
sin tiempo pero no se preocupen
realizaré un par de ejemplos más sobre
esto porque de verdad me interesa que
ustedes comprendan la distribución
binomial antes
pasar a la distribución normal